tag täglich erreichen uns bilder von
menschen auf der flucht jetzt kommen
flüchtlinge in überfüllten zügen in wien
und münchen am im herzen europas das
elend wird greifbar christen sind
verpflichtet flüchtlingen zu helfen sagt
mein gast der jesuit und ordensmann
peter balazs er kennt die situation von
migranten weltweit er ist nämlich
internationaler direktor des flüchtlings
dienstes der jesuiten
pater balleis 60 millionen menschen auf
der flucht weltweit schlafe noch
vielleicht aus müdigkeit
die zahl ist ja wirklich in den jahren
der ich die leitung des flüchtlings habt
seit 88 jahren aufgegangen dramatisch
aufgegangen von 40 auf 60 mio man muss
hier klar unterscheiden sind sehr viele
interne flüchtlinge die im eigenen land
flüchtlinge sind in syrien sind sechs
millionen und mehr interne flüchtlingen
die anderes land gar nicht verlassen
aber leben nicht mehr dort wo sie vorher
gelebt haben dann so 20 millionen
flüchtlinge man muss hier sehr klar
unterscheiden den begriff migranten zu
dazu kommen im grunde noch weltweit 150
millionen oder mehr migranten aber
migranten es gibt verschiedene gerade
von freiwilligkeit oder arbeitsmigranten
für uns und es ist der begriff wir reden
hier von flüchtlingen menschen die
gezwungen sind ihr land zu verlassen
um schutz zu finden das ist
allerwichtigste was menschen brauchen in
kriegssituationen also wenn wir die
bilder so sehen menschen riskieren nicht
ihr leben und das ihrer familie und ein
besseres hemd in europa zu haben sondern
die brauchen schutz die laufen von einem
krieg davon dass eben der flüchtlings
begriff der genfer konvention wie sich
sagen eben bedroht an leib und leben
politisch verfolgt kriegssituation die
bilder in münchen sie sind ja in
augsburg mal geboren und aufgewachsen in
bayern
haben sie die gefreut diese solidarität
der menschen die diese flüchtlinge
empfangen haben nach all diesen attacken
auch in deutschland nach diesen
rechtsradikalen ja durchaus weil das
eine positive reaktion ist und ich würde
sagen dass die haltung der mehrheit der
bevölkerung die hier das hat natürlich
auch mit erfahrung zu tun
die geschichte welt mal anfangen in 1946
also meine mutter in die kleine
scheinbar noch von meinem vater rhein
gerne dann da kann millionen von
flüchtlingen was hat die amerikanische
administration gemacht dieser umgang hat
die flüchtlinge auf die dörfer verteilt
für sechs jahre waren unser mattern
haares 23
flüchtlings ehepaar de wir hatten eine
gute beziehungen zu nehmen sie waren ein
ehepaar wurde für uns oma und opa weil
meine großeltern früher starten die
großmutter und
ja gottseidank gibt auch eine gewisse
integrität dass die eigenen eltern sich
sagt jetzt anständig den menschen
gegenüber verhalten haben die haben
natürlich auch geholfen und waren teil
da gab es mal was zu essen gab es arbeit
und die andern geholfen dass deutschland
wieder aufzubauen also es gab viele
problematische situationen in unserer
geschichte unserer jüngsten geschichte
europa supermacht deutschlands die jetzt
mit sie schon vergleich das aber nicht
in der in der gleichen weise also da
klingt schon hoffnung heraus dass das
problem eigentlich ja heute lösbar ist
natürlich prägung aus ihrer kindheit wir
wollen ja heute ein gespräch führen
jetzt nicht primär über die
flüchtlingspolitik über die europäische
schweizer flüchtlingspolitik sondern
über die arbeit im der jesuiten ihres
ordens mehr karte vorbereitet wo man
sieht wo sie überall tätig sind das ist
eindrücklich dass ich jetzt mal die
büros traf von daraus wird dann
gearbeitet
sagen sie mal mit jesuiten ich meinen
sie tragen ja keine ordenstracht es gibt
eine ausnahme oder papst franziskus ist
ja auch ein jesuit in seiner weißen
gewand aber scherz beiseite also keine
ordenstracht wie viele jesuiten sind
denn da jetzt weltweit unterwegs im
flüchtlingsdienst arbeiten vollzeit so
70-80 mit uns also dann natürlich
ordensfrauen
50 und viele also nicht hier sieht man
soll ein absinken der leyen sind
professionelle leute
sagen wir für 1800 plus mehrere tausend
flüchtlinge selbst die als lehrer kommen
die leute verlassen die land und bringen
ihre fähigkeiten mit und mit denen kann
man dann auch die schulen mit der
leighton in den lagern und verschiedene
sie sind in praktisch allen
konfliktgebieten weltweit ja hat meinen
über die 3 35 jahre ist ist der
flüchtlingsdienst gewachsen und wir
haben büros also in allen regionen der
welt vor allem afrika und im nahen osten
aber die schwerpunkte die ich auch vor
allem reise ist die zone in afrika von
westafrikas zahl also wenn man nachts
noch sind und unter nahen osten und das
ist etwas um uns verständlich zu machen
warum jetzt diese situation haben in
europa europa hat die beiden größten
konfliktherde an der haustüre also ist
die salz ohne von von mali nord die
gewog
ramadan südsudan nordsudan
zentralafrika ich will durch die geniale
norden aufbrechen und die sahara ist
nicht mehr die über kehrt man in drei
tagen mit lastwagen und dann der ganze
nahe osten und wenn man noch die ukraine
den konflikt hinzu dann sind drei
konfliktherde an der haustür euro was
ich sage das nur damit die menschen
verstehen was geht denn eigentlich hier
ab das ist ja ein neu die intensität die
zahlen die dramatik ist viel größer mein
flüchtlingsströme und migration schon
gab es immer aber wie es jetzt gewachsen
den letzten zwei jahren hat mit dieser
globalen situation an der haustür
europas das ist eine herausforderung
ist eben ein vorteil wenn sie keine
ordenstracht tragen sieht wir haben
jetzt sie haben ein kreuz oder dass sie
als priester kennzeichnen dabei keine
ordenstracht ersten vorteil
ignatius wollte dass wir ihr
ordensgründer dass wir in der welt den
arbeiten und und
ist jetzt die kleidung als wir sind da
mehr praktisch gar wenn in rom irgendwas
offiziellen gepackt ich kann das sag ich
jetzt mal zeigt schon die uniformen des
cola und so aber was hat jetzt nötig ist
das ist sind wir es wenn er sich
ideologisch in der ganzen geschichte
wichtig ist dass wir dort sind an den
fronten in den schwierigen gebieten wo
auch andere organisationen die un
partnerorganisation sich abmühen mit dem
problem und wir sind ja die einzige aber
ich finde es sehr wichtig dass wir als
christen als kirche und als kirche
organisation auch unseren bescheidenen
beitrag leisten indem in der thematik
dies in dieser welt tag zur zeit gibt
und auch vorher schon gab und
wahrscheinlich immer ein stück geben
wird sie kommen zurück aus der
zentralafrikanischen republik sie sind
gereist auch in den kongo haben sie ein
bild mitgebracht aus einem
flüchtlingslager in der demokratischen
republik kongo
was machen sie da konkret
das ist ein bild das ist in assisi
von goma rauf in die berge
sind internes flüchtlingslager also
nicht diese nicht aus dem land geflohen
seien im eigenen land von von hier nach
hier sind manchmal nur zehn kilometer
weg weil eine bestimmte rebellengruppe
hier die leute vertrieben hat sind immer
mehr leute in diesen lagen nach assisi
gekommen hier machen wir eine arbeit
wir helfen schulen aber auch weiter das
sehen sie eine sehr alte werden ältere
dame alte menschen und auch behinderte
sind oft noch mehr betroffen auf der
flucht
als hat sag jetzt mal leute sich als 10
oder nicht behindert sind und für die
für die mehr sagen und fünf verletzt man
um walter über sich sagt so dass wir für
die arbeiten die die begleitenden
besuchen und so weiter
da kenne ich eine frau die war immer in
ihrem bett gelegen wie mehrfach besucht
und jede nicht erzählen wir versorgt
eine alte dame und ihr wunsch war vor
ihren eigenen haus begraben zu sein
haben wir 4000 dollar ein häuschen
gebaut das holz das in würde lebt und
monat später starb die hätte damit ist
auf die geschichte von ein oder zwei
personen ein behindertes mädchen die
einen wasserkopf gesagt habe das mädchen
gesehen nein diese lager in assisi die
tu lisa habe ich unser team sagt machen
wir da was das mädchen das ist ein
hydrocephalus
wenn du da gesessen dreijähriges und
dann haben unsere leute die haben sie zu
msf gebracht und dann also den etagen
bekommt jetzt sofort hierher und jährige
reagiere hits und lebensbedingungen
haben sie verbessern hat man noch
rollstuhl gebracht für sie und man
konnte die qualität des lebens in ihrem
land verbessern sie es dann auch dass
sie dürfte transferiert ja das ist vor
allem das entscheidende ist und das auch
für uns als als normal ein
charakteristikum und vielleicht auch als
kirchliche organisationen noch mal
entscheiden
wir besuchen die leute wir tun sich das
sachen verteilte das begleitende
flüchtlinge bei ihnen sein ist
entscheidend für unseren ansatz und das
ist
ganz wichtig
aus der heraus sich dann der rest der
arbeit auch entwickler sie haben bildung
erwähnt oder das würde ich jetzt von
jesuiten erwarten viele hütten sind an
hochschulen tätig was heißt das konkret
jetzt bildung in ein flüchtlingslager wo
es so ausschaut ja gut es gibt lager
also bin zb im charter- haben wir in
flüchtlingslagern die leitung von den
grundschulen und den klimatischen für
23.000 kinder in zusammenarbeiten im
urin acr
33.000 kinder überhaupt nicht insgesamt
haben wir so 140000 im letzten jahr in
bildungsaktivitäten wir haben sozusagen
wir sind auch bekannt in der in der in
der uhrenwelt oder ngo welt als eine
organisation die vor allem im
psychosozialen
und im
bildungsbereich
service leisten und anbieten und wir
haben eine palette vom vom vorschule vom
kindergarten bis zur online universität
die leute dann auch aus mit computern ja
natürlich vor ein paar jahren haben wir
angefangen diese idee umzusetzen im
zusammenarbeit mit universitäten in
flüchtlingslagern wir online eine
universitäts degree anzubieten und
dieses bildet es breitet sich aus und
die tief die die kurse werden mehr so zu
sagen wir haben studenten in camp im
malawi italica in jordanien amman inn
hat man gar nichts
die sin eingeschriebenen studenten von
ritchies universität denn welche süden
universität studieren zusammen im
virtuellen klassenzimmer
und von verschiedenen nationen und
hintergründen und
die qualität der reflexion der
flüchtlinge ist eine andere qualität als
wir wenn man so 20 jährigen hernehmen
der halt jetzt gerade in die universität
geht für das fasziniert auch die
professoren die online die leute
begleiten was sagen sie zu dem argument
von kritikern eben die bildung wird
einfach dazu führen dass dann die leute
die was gelernt haben wieder auswandern
und zum beispiel richtung europa drängen
nein das ist gehört anders dass der eine
oder andere schon
irgendwie sein weg findet und da sind
wir auch nicht wir sind ich
sag jetzt mal die herren des lebens der
anderen leute ist jeder mensch seine
freiheit so und seien dann weg zu gehen
wir bilden vor allem aus deshalb machen
wir die online wir machen jedes koller
ships dass wir leute nach kanada bringen
und dass sie dann in kanada bleiben so
zu sagen dass man die klügsten so
abschöpft und danach kann er die anderen
lässt man in afrika sonne wir bringen
die universität dorthin
wo die leute brauchen und den massiv sie
die werden keine resettlement programm
haben zum beispiel oder in süd zu deinem
ab anfang sondern wir breiten programm
also umsiedlungsprogramm also schuldig
ja ja englisch wir bringen die
universität um also bessere skills in
den lagen sind vor allem ich sag mal es
reicht nicht mehr in afrika und überall
auf der welt dass die buben schreinerei
lernen und die medien nehmen sondern
verbraucht sophisticated also
fähigkeiten
lehrausbildung englisch computer weiter
und das machen wir wir bringen die
skills die die fähigkeiten dorthin damit
sich dort die situation verändert es ist
auch kein programm wo einer allein
online mit einer universität studiert
sondern immer in einer gruppe man formt
eine eine gemeinschaft von lernenden die
neu denken also im grunde auch für uns
wir sind deshalb auch in der
traditionellen humanitas ist in kurse
führungskader philosophie logik und so
manche also macht sich redlich ab von
dem was wir rennen von vielen
missionsstationen wie das vielleicht
früher war anderer schauplatz hier im
nordirak sicherheit sorgt ja noch was
sozusagen ihre bildung warum es ist
strategisch es gab eine andere landkarte
wenn sie diese landkarte nehmen
jetzt war alles rot darauf hier aber
wenn sie denn der eine landkarte nehmen
wo es zeigt den den bildungsstandard und
den den menschlichen
entwicklungsstandard also dass bildung
gesundheit und
pro-kopf-einkommen natürlich weil die
schweiz geht es ganz grün oder im ganz
blauen bereich aber diese bereiche der
welt hierauf sind tiefrot und
hier auch afghanistan und ich bring ein
slogan
niedrige bildung hohe konflikt
und der sowohl die leute keine
ausbildung haben keine bildung haben
werden sie manipuliert in die kriege das
ist man nimmt den jungen leuten die
zukunft dann haben sie keine chance also
mit bensel von daher ist bildung unser
strategien um den teufelskreis von
gewalt zu brechen es ist nicht beweist
schöne sind die schule zu gehen sondern
um die kinder raus zu halten aus dem
konflikt sie zu schützen sowie für
unsere arbeit ist vor allem in den
ländern wo die flüchtlinge kommen dann
kommen sie gar nicht hierher weise dort
eine als zehn sehr überzeugend klingt
sehr überzeugen anderer schauplatz hier
in nordirak bei einer familie jetzt
haben wir eine frage wenn man die suite
und flüchtlingshilfe hört ich meinen sie
waren in diesem jahr in syrien selber
dass es im nordirak sie reisen wirklich
in die gefährlichsten regionen soll für
14 haben wir weder sei aber gut mit
mission ist das nicht schwierig sie
haben ja viel mit muslimen zu bekommen
sie nicht den verdacht
trainieren da hat
es war ja lange die haltung bei uns auch
in der organisation ja als christliche
organisationen können wir nicht im namen
islamischer bereich aber nein wir sind
sogar privilegiert weil wir also eine
organisation vom glauben her arbeiten
verstehen ja auch was der glaube den
andern bedeuten können das zumindest
respektieren der respekt ist
entscheidend und dann natürlich immer
auch in den augen der muslime und auch
noch doch noch eine religion des buches
und so haben wir eigentlich eine gute
wir arbeiten sehr viel mit muslime die
hälfte unserer mitarbeiter in syrien
auch afghanistan die meisten sind
muslime und da ist kein konflikt klar es
gibt die grundregel und ist auch ein
humanitär von der humanität das prinzip
der humanitären arbeit die neutralität
dass man nicht die arbeit als dem macht
ausnützt die macht aus ist um leute
sozusagen zur eiskristall sondern wir
halten uns daran hier reden nicht von
religion aber die liebe gottes
liebevoll zu handeln und respektvoll
das
versteht jeder und das ist auch der kern
des christentums nicht nicht die worte
sondern die taten das kann einem das
leben kosten einer ihrer mitbrüder wurde
erschossen in syrien frans van der lugt
ja haben sie dann auf reagiert der franz
von der luft der ja geblieben in der
altstadt von hans
mit flüchtlingen oder mit menschen die
nicht
dieses altstadt mehr verlassen konnten
da war noch rebellenkämpfer
und er wurde dann warum
wer hat ein interesse erschossen er war
sich des risikos bewusst das war seine
solidarität ich habe den ort besucht
sein grab auch jetzt ende juni und es
werden ist ein wallfahrtsort die leute
kommen jetzt langsam nicht zu wirken
diese zerstörte altstadt das ist man
geht durch eine stadt ist was ihr die
bilder aus deutschland durch die ruinen
ein ganzes die in der stadtkern und und
trotzdem fängt irgendwo wie das leben an
die schwestern richten renovieren wie
dein haus ein gebäude wo der
rebellenführer war
und es wird mit einem behindertenheim
und abends haben wir dann in den anderen
teil wohl nicht zerstört war die
erstkommunion von 50 kindern gefeiert
wir erleben die total zerstört in die
ruinen und dann doch das leben wieder
und da gibt's die nächste generation und
wenn man für diese kinder arbeitet
arbeiten wir die zukunft die alten
kämpfer werden wir nicht ändern aber die
zukunft kann man trotzdem gestalten in
der krise in konflikt und dass unser
einsatz daran glauben wir den zu helfen
in friedlich
dass die bildung geben eine perspektive
haben den kindern da ist dann auch die
hoffen und die kraft im land das heißt
auch nach dieser erschießung arbeiten
sie nach wie vor unverständlich ja
gerade deshalb und da machen jetzt auch
eine schule auf die regierung hatte die
schulen weggenommen sind 960
sozialismus und ganz zerstörte gebäude
geben sie sogar jetzt den orden läuten
wir den ordens zurück der kirche ok dann
nehmen so kaputt ist was man der schule
war gleich nebenan
und hoffe dass mir dann was aufbauen
denn wir müssen lang versieht hoffnung
es gibt die tragen die leider
gratisticket ändern ich kann es ja auch
nicht aufhalten ich kenne die syrien vor
dem krieg und das ist schmerzlich wenn
man sieht ein land hat einige motiviert
war nicht ideal aber was jetzt ist das
wollte doch keiner und trotzdem
geschehen diese dinge auch viel als
vielen politischen fehlern und falschen
interessen ganz klar aber
was bleibt jetzt wird die zukunft können
wir trotzdem und darin ist dann auch
wieder die kraft und flüchtlinge
menschen
haben die widerstandszone bauen dann
wieder auf und man ihnen dabei hilft
dann ist es eigentlich auch eine arbeit
die auch ein händler sind ich deshalb
habe ich habe jetzt richtig schlafen da
sie nicht den bin deprimiert oder sogar
von der liebe gottes gesprochen ja das
ist christliche pflicht flüchtlingen zu
helfen ja klar das heißt aber nicht dass
sie jene die nicht helfen oder sagen ich
nehme keine flüchtlinge erfordert ein
nein nein das ist das ist das ist
sozusagen pflicht
wird es ist jetzt ein sagen wir sind wir
sind gerufen dazu betriebe mit
barmherzigkeit nicht noch schlimmer
pflicht bei ihnen oder wenn es weiterhin
aber warum eigentlich das schult den
leuten ein schlechtes gefühl zu geben
hilft nicht da motiviere ich nicht die
menschen ja auch nicht hier in europa
darum habe ich nicht den immer die
vorwürfe zu machen weil sie schlecht
weil diese sprache hilft nicht es ist
schwierig es ist schwierig so viele
leute zu verstehen aber man kann den
leuten helfen besser zu verstehen ist
gefordert
gms hängt im erbgut des christentums für
den anderen da zu sein zu leben wo ein
mensch der nachbarn otis das ist im
alten testament für den fremden für den
schwachen da zu sein für den und das ist
einfach
für christen das mandat und aber auch
europa das seine christlichen wurzeln
hat und der papst hat ja letztes jahr in
straßburg tagt sagt sich europa hatte
die die menschliche würde also auch
jemand jetzt nicht nur kristisiert der
zuhörer dass wir glauben noch an die
würde der mensch nun dass wir das
nachtleben
in zwei tagen sagen europa ist sehr
gefordert in seiner eigenen identität so
wie wir diese schwierige situation
lösen oder damit umgehen entscheidet
sich auch was wir wirklich sind was
wirklich unsere werte sind als europa ob
wir wirklich von der würde des menschen
her sehen
es ist ja eigentlich ein positives
zeichen dass die leute nach europa
wollen
wir sollten eigentlich darauf nein sie
von uns erwarten dass sie hier als
menschen behandelt werden nicht nur denn
und sollten dort hingehen es woanders
hingehen seine gehen hier ich habe uns
schwestern im kloster in baldegg das ist
hier im luzernischen besucht die haben
zwei familien aus syrien aufgenommen ihr
habt eine reportage für die
kulturplattform bei uns geschrieben
würden sie sagen dass sollte vermehrt
größter öffnen paar häuser öffnen getan
werden als hat auch der papst franziskus
in rom auch gesagt stadt das alte halb
steht also halb leer stehende gebäude
umwandeln
hotels für pilger und touristen dass man
lieber die häuser herinnen für dass man
familien öffnen und das geschieht
eigentlich viel in der richtung das ist
selbst für jesuiten aber das sind sie
flüchtlinge sondern es geht um
obdachlose in rom da haben wir ein
bürogebäude vermietet an erdgeschoss in
der peripherie und das wäre das nicht
mehr vermietet ist dass reisebüros
ausgezogen sondern das wird so eine
obdachlose übernachtungs stelle das ist
gut man muss konkrete zeichen setzen
auch im headquarter in der hauptstelle
ganz klar dass er sich glaubt dieses
foto von dem jungen der an einer küste
in der türkei geschwemmt wurde ein
dreijähriger toter irgendwas hat mich
sehr beschäftigt haben sie das bild
gesehen ich habe es heute morgen ist und
ich verstehe warum das man kann mit
zahlen kann man die menschen tot
schlagen dann irgendwie ab da kann sich
keiner vorstellen aber eine einzelne
geschichte ist immer entscheidend
irgendwo zu verstehen die dramatik
dieser die eltern haben ihr kind ist
wahrscheinlich etwas bord gefallen ist
ertrunken ist der vierjährige und der
vierjährige könnte ein vier tage von
jedem von uns irgendwas sein und werden
dann wird konkreter dann wird diese
menschliche es ist dann sehr ich besuche
die hälfte meiner zeit bei sich als
internationaler direkt an die basis ich
muss flüchtige person ich mache auch
gerne fotos damit erinner mich und die
menschen weil das motiviert auch nicht
ich bin kein verwalter ja in der arbeit
sondern die dd tätig das mitleiden nicht
mitleidig tun sondern mit leiden
mitfühlen ist ganz entscheiden als
motivation um dann auch zu handeln und
dann auch als direkter zu sagen und hier
machen wir was ja es gibt immer viele
grün ja wir haben wir haben jetzt nicht
ist schwierig nein hier sind die leute
machen hier was ich habe immer ein
bisschen getrieben klassen ist nicht neu
im mittelmeer wir haben einen beitrag
vorbereiteten von vor einem jahr das von
phillips an unserem kollegen der dafür
den europäischen zivis preis gewonnen
hat in diesem jahr der beitrag ist aus
der rundschau vom elften juni 2014
vorsichtig werden die flüchtlinge ins
rettungsboot geholt jeder handgriff muss
sitzen frauen und kinder werden zuerst
gerettet und susann georgia gebracht
kapitän dolphins bei dieser ruhigen sie
kann dass noch ein langer einsatz werden
viele boote sind in den letzten tagen
von libyen aus gestartet sie nutzen das
schöne wetter und die ruhige see kommen
alle auf einen
die ersten flüchtlinge werden in empfang
genommen vor allem kinder haben hunger
und durst die reiser beharrt trotz
ruhiger see fast einen tag lang waren
sie unter der heißen sonne unterwegs
die rettungsboote holen immer wieder
neue flüchtlinge aus ihren booten ab auf
den gesichtern die strapazen der reise
alte sind völlig erschöpft
schwangere müssen ärztlich versorgt
werden
alle sind erleichtert
die meisten hier kommen aus syrien vor
allem junge männer aber auch ganze
familien
zehn stunden waren wir auf dem boot mit
meiner frau und meinen kindern
ja das war vor einem jahr die lage ist
immer noch dramatisch auch in diesem
sommer in diesen tagen wird das so
weitergehen
wahrscheinlich wird es noch
stück ja weil der der konflikt im nahen
osten ist noch nicht ausgestanden ist
noch nicht vorbei und
es
kann vielleicht sogar schlimmer werden
ich weiß nicht die die die der nahe
osten ist der exklusiv und man weiß ich
wie die die
islamistische staat reagiert wir haben
einen konkreten fall wir arbeiten in
aleppo wir arbeiten immer noch in aleppo
in dem vom regime von assad immer der
regierung kontrollierten bereich
hinziehen aber wir haben seit april
haben wir es zunehmende sorge dass
eventuell gs islamistischen staat und
die nutzer auch in islamistische gruppe
im grunde alle übernehmen werden das ist
das assad regime nicht behalten kann das
ist eine stadt mit war wird über zwei
millionen oder mir die christen jetzt
gehört in jüngster zeit alle christen
gehen jetzt weg und auch viele
muslimische flüchtlinge und wenn man so
eine katastrophe dass so eine große
stadt
auch noch übernommen wird und dann haben
einige 100000 mehr flüchtlinge also die
die verzweiflung der menschen die nimmt
zu wo sollen sehen gegen den libanon
macht die grenzen zu in die türkei
können sie gehen aber in die türkei
trotz vielen lagern aber die menschen
sehen da keine zukunft sie haben diesen
sommer die flüchtlingspolitik euro in
europa ich muss doch darf kommen aus
kritisiert abschottung statt hilfe aber
wenn sie europäischer flüchtlings
minister werden werden sie da
er die mechanismen die die instrumente
die
europa hat die funktionieren nicht mehr
in dieser größe von krise ja es hat ja
auch die die die deutsche kanzlerin
merkel
das dublin-abkommen
dass davon spricht die flüchtlinge
müssen wieder dorthin geschickt werden
wo ist ihr erster richtig saniert werden
dass sie funktioniert nicht es sind
zahlen was soll man jetzt wieder alle
nach griechenland schicken und so weiter
man muss anders handeln muss neu zu
wählen sind dann sind wir natürlich
verzweifelt erschüttert über die 71 dem
lastwagen ersticken in der ungarischen
grenze nach österreich und so weiter und
dann merken wie viel geld die leute
bezahlen an die verbrecher die der not
aussetzen man kann andere instrumente
schaffen dass der stadt werden sie 3000
zahlen werden dies kann die boots über
fahrt ja welche konkret dass wir
vielleicht die schweiz hat er die
möglichkeit in schweizer konsulaten dass
das humanitäre visa zu geben dass
menschen legal - für drei monate die
möglichkeit haben nach europa oder in
die schweiz um dann ihren antrag als
asylsuchender als flüchtling zu stellen
um dann entschieden zu werden das ist
eine politische debatte hier diese
konsulats wie soll man die wieder
einführen soll aber ein großes
kontingent an syrischen flüchtlingen
soll in die schweiz kommt es wird
organisiert aber jetzt wenn sie europa
schaue ich mein 800 1000 flüchtlinge in
deutschland möglicherweise in diesem
jahr das ist doch verständlich dass die
leute sagen wir können nicht alle
menschen hier aufnehmen das ist richtig
und die alle menschen werden auch gar
nicht kommen sind im sommer die zahl im
nahen osten ja der libanon mit
viereinhalb millionen hat eineinhalb
millionen syrische flüchtlinge
das spürt man das land ist voll aber die
haben die jordanien die nachbarländer 6
millionen der syrer sind ja im land
geblieben also
die angst dass die alle hierher kommen
und wenn sie mal die 250.000 mann den
man jetzt groß als syrer sind vergleicht
mit den drei millionen flüchtlingen der
würde dann ist es weniger als zehn
prozent also die angst dass alle hierher
kommen wollen und alle herkommen und es
ist nicht berechtigt und natürlich kann
man jetzt auch nicht sagen jetzt müssen
alle merken dass ich aber ewig kommen
dass man die menschen die dort keine
keine zukunft mehr haben keinen schutz
außenschutz dass man denen die
möglichkeit gibt eine filiale weise ohne
risiko ihren flüchtlingsschutz zu
bekommen das halte ich für ein gebot der
stunde also würden sie sagen gottfried
locher dass der präsident des
schweizerischen evangelischen
kirchenbundes sagte in einem interview
im juli diesen jahres
konsequente asylpolitik heißt eben
grenzen zu kontrollieren im interesse
jener die wirklich an leib und leben
bedroht sind nächstenliebe bedeutet auch
ehrlichkeit asyl ist nur für
flüchtlingen möglich würden sie das
unterschreiben
ich würde es so sagen also von da
unterscheide ich auch sehr stark dass
ich nicht von migranten sprechen sondern
wirklich von flüchtlingen von crysis
eingangs bestands player und dass man
natürlich die stimme regeln muss denn
man darf auch soziale gefüge nicht in
die in balance ende und balazs ein
gleichgewicht bringen weil dann kann man
diese negativen reaktionen haben von
neonazis und so leuten und es muss
natürlich
gesteuert sein in einer guten weise das
ist klar weil sonst funktioniert sind
die müssen ja auch integriert werden und
dass ich weiß jetzt kostet alles auch
geld das ist manchmal weil es so die
zahlen was ist in bayern und deutschland
haben und wenn das geld geben wird dann
wird man die alle in die schule schicken
im libanon mehr schulen machen wir haben
dort auch schon so weiter aber es ist
dass man das dass das alles wichtig und
ich denke wenn man den menschen
eine legale weise sondern eine geordnete
weise die möglichkeit gibt den
flüchtlingen anspruch also zu
repräsentieren dass man den druck raus
nimmt
und nicht mehr die leute in die hände
der verbrecher und der
dann haben sie ja ihren ansatz erklärt
eben die hilfe vor ort sie sind als eben
nicht europäischer flüchtlings minister
sondern direktor noch dass es wird ein
flüchtlings dienstes wenn sie so
weltweiten unterwegs sind in diesen
krisenregionen hatten sie nie angst um
ihr eigenes leben
eigentlich nicht so
afghanistan muss man ein bisschen
aufpassen vor ein paar jahren sind noch
rumgelaufen in herat und so weiter aber
das sagt wir werden ein letztes jahr
einen unserer jesuiten von indien als
geisel
geisler von den taliban für achteinhalb
monate als natürlich die idee dass wir
haben unsere sicherheit und
vorsichtsmaßnahmen sehr hoch gefahren
muss aber werden sie vor ort auch
geführt oder dass brenzlige situation
möglichst nicht denn wir verlassen uns
auf und natürlich auch unsere fahrrad
sind natürlich auch vorsicht wenn es
jetzt in afghanistan verhält man sich
jetzt anders als wir im kongo frei
herumlaufen kann also hängt von der
situation ab aber eines ist richtig es
deren sehr viele menschen von vielen
organisationen in humanitärer arbeit
journalisten und die die ihr leben
riskieren und auch dass die die arbeit
mit flüchtlingen den konfliktgebieten
ist es schwierig und gefährlicher
geworden
ohne zweifel für alle
jetzt turnusgemäß geben sie amt zurück
in den nächsten wochen wie schaut's aus
mit ihrem nachfolger haben sie ein
geschenk parat für ihn
wir haben uns entschieden dass wir jetzt
im jahr
der barmherzigkeit dieser partie haben 8
dezember aus ruft dazu sagen hier die
als flüchtlinge sind konkrete geste
konkreter beitrag dass wir einfach ich
sag mal so hunderttausend kinder mehr in
die schulen bringen in den nächsten
jahren das würde darf ja auch geld
sammeln und da auch zusammen arbeiten
hier mit der jesuitenmission in der
schweiz und die schweizer helfen uns
aber mehr sei aber eine bürde als ein
geschenk
das ist ja wird klar was heißt hier böte
dass es das ist ja nicht das ist ein
dienst dieses amt das ist nicht wie eine
gloriose machtposition und hier der
super manager sondern es ist ein dienst
und
die hat es das ist das ziel dafür ist er
da dafür sind wir da die mission die
sendung und das auch hier mehr zu tun
denn wir sind meiner zeit ist die
organisation ja auch gewachsen fast um
60 70 prozent in acht jahren ja als
antwort auf die wachsenden krisen da
kann ich ja nicht zu sagen ja machen wir
leben heute rücken müssen wir mehr tun
es ist wer wir laufen immer ein stück
hinterher wir sind nicht auf der
gewinnerseite und das eines muss man
vielleicht auch verstehen wenn man mit
flüchtlingen arbeitet wir arbeiten
sozusagen auf der verliererseite immer
auf der seite der schwächeren von
menschen die vertrieben werden die nicht
gemocht werden und soll auf deren seite
und mama wenn der krieg wieder losgeht
dann werden auch unsere schulen mit der
kaputtgemacht geht haben wir wieder neue
vater balleis ganz herzlichen dank für
dieses gespräch für diesen einblick in
ihre arbeit
schwestern in einem geschlossenen
kloster und eine männer eishockey
mannschaft mit einem film über eine
ungewöhnliche begegnung geht es hier
jetzt in der sternstunde religion gleich
weiter nicht verpassen sollten sie auch
das gespräch mit dem historiker fritz
stern heute in der sternstunde
philosophie ich wünsche ihnen weiter
einen schönen sonntag